this gentleman in particular is fresh
from Green Bay Wisconsin where his coach
decided to give him a get out of get out
of jail free pass if you will from the
National Football League's mandatory
minicamp up there in Green Bay good to
see you Mike Daniels good the suits who
they you got the hall pass huh I do I do
I love it it's like now we're going into
camp saying okay we all do coach he gave
us a week off yeah we need to we need to
bring it so Mike McCarthy lets you know
when that you're not you're not
mandatorily required to be at the
mandatory minicamp how did you let you
know that Mike he'll have a a vet select
meeting you know the week before and
he'll tell us you guys are excused on
these days and that's it that's it yeah
i father you thank him you give me a big
ol hug big ol hug
so it actually helps in the long run
that you're not out of mandatory
minicamp is that what you're saying
what does especially as you get a little
bit older it's I'm a defensive lineman I
can only run around in my underwear so
much like we're not even that we're not
hitting you know we don't have any pads
on them I are just how many times can I
just run around guys I need to hit
somebody you know need he understands
that and with a lot of his veteran guys
and we know that we all know the system
so it's hey we get our work and all
right you guys good go ready for camp
great for Susan and in year 7 now the
National Football League you're entering
year seven yes how how different has is
the game than when you entered do you
this I just changed well it slowed down
I'll say that light as a player but in
terms of play call and style a lot of
same coordinators are still around so
the game hasn't changed to dress with
well you've got a new defensive
coordinator now and Mike best and how
how have you found your new DC I mean in
how it's different if a system is it
gonna be for Packers fans to see you out
there with the rest of the defense oh
they're they're gonna love the changes
just just flat-out and I say that
because we love the changes what do you
love about him he's aggressive
a really no-nonsense type of attitude
he's gonna get after you and kill Matata
keep it like vulnerable says again kill
mentality keep it likable learn about he
said learn about is that is an acronym
or is that something that you've come up
with it I would love to take the credit
for it but it's his so yeah a bit
likable and learn about that's right
what do you like about it then I mean
what is is he freeing you up to do more
stuff that you are yeah yeah the chains
off man
you know it's time he's cutting hounds
loose all across the board and we have
the talent to do some good things you
know and I'm excited I've really loved
what I've seen from him and I've said
this on a few different mediums I'm
gonna tell you please Aaron stone about
Aaron stone a good number of picks to
our two rookies and he driving upset
about it because he's looking like good
that's good I like that so it's it's
it's is exciting so he is not upset that
he's getting picked off in these
practices so yes he knows a competitor
and he's one of the greatest of all time
he though he doesn't want to mess up but
I think he loves the fact that if I'm
throwing picks against these guys and I
can only imagine what somebody's more
under the bus words can we put in like
damn hackers schedule hold on a second
well we do plate it I'm gonna make it
easy for you to NFC west AFC East and we
do you plan the Patriots we do oh no in
New England isn't that fun
well you tell me we won last time then
he won a Super Bowl you know so I mean
and so tracking down Brady will that
have any extra meaning because of his
status
absolutely absolutely I've actually I
got well acquaintance with Tom
last time we played and Mike Neil and I
converged on a game course a game
winning big oh yeah game winning sack
and they went up there for a field goal
missed we got the ball ran a clock up so
you have histories what you're saying
when you say you got acquainted I
thought like you actually met him and
you were like yeah I know Tom but just
not in a way that hey we're at that we
shake hands boom hey my shorter players
meeting your chest so you said that
Aaron Rodgers should be the highest-paid
guy of course the history how much if a
cut has he given you then you just raise
your he's gonna he's gonna help me get a
Super Bowl ring yeah but not playing
against his him and those guys every day
in practice we've all got some people
it's like art so because you're
practicing against the best right
absolutely what's it like being a team
minutes he's funny man he's a jokester
and for him to have the prestige he has
he treats everybody the same whether
you're day one guy or you one of his
favorite targets
he's shows the same I'll respect that
everybody coastal border and I mean
that's true sign of a leader house Clay
Matthews doing him or his nose was the
whole package I don't think I'll be
doing commercials anytime soon maybe
maybe something like what does I call
rhinoplasty I don't know but uh some
about shades cuz he's - black guy but
yeah he got yeah I mean we all wallet
pretty good man charity softball game
the day before at the big slick charity
in Kansas City and I thought to myself
there but for the grace goes anybody
right there I mean he really took one
who was the one who hit hit the ball so
was do we know who's the one the guy
that was just staying it was I the one
that hit the ball because that's a if it
was him that's Lucas Patrick is one of
our guards this is Patrick yeah one of
one of Aaron Rodgers protectors broke
Clay Matthews nose so what you're
telling me destroyed it I mean I was
play in the locker room when it's all
said and done I mean it's a freak
accident
you know it's contact sports not good
reflexes by Clay oh my god your hands I
worried about his future too much drives
are dangerous let's take a 60-second
break when we come back I want to talk
about your football camp and all the
other stuff that you'll be doing this
summer and then just pick a little bit
more at what you're talking about
winning a Super Bowl for Green Bay I
don't want to see if you're making a
guarantee right here in the Rich Eisen
show see you now I'm looking
peripherally to see how he's looking at
me we're back in 60 seconds
[Music]
McDaniel's back here on the Rich Eisen
show and last time I saw you sir prior
to today was at the Super Bowl in
Minnesota is where it was the Pat
Summerall dinner in support of st. Jude
Children's Research Hospital and
broccoli and I uh I think I told you
about this the next day but the
auctioneer was at there was those s
point of the night where we're just
asking for straight donations from
people in the room raise your hands if
you want to give this much or whatever
and she started a 25 thousand dollar
donation level and no hands went up in
the room with the exception of yours
Mike Daniels and you raised your hand
and said I'll give a hundred thousand
and the place went not so good on you
thank you thank you for doing that on
behalf of everybody if it's part of that
that evening did you know Tony Dungy I
mean what were you what was your
relationship to the sobbing you know
I've never met him and I've said you
know growing up beautiful ball fan I
knew of him and I always had a lot of
respect for him as you know Pat
Summerall and all these guys and I was I
wasn't familiar with st. Jude's at all I
didn't know that they didn't charge and
they they covered the fees for everybody
the families I had no idea when I said
that's it I definitely well how can I
hope you know how can I help I did the
math in my head I said this recovered
this many days this many families okay
yeah yes and then likewise I also wanted
to you know that I've been in plenty of
charity events and I'm like that's kind
of that part of night like come on
someone okay let's get this party
started
and you did because the the donations
started flowing right after that and
Dungey was really touched you know and
actually I'll be honest it made me just
look up like wait a minute I know he
hasn't been in a league that long and
wait a minute like did he play for the
Colts that he played for the Buccaneers
or like how did you meet Tony who was
the honoree that night so you were just
in town and just got invited and just in
town and we went you know saw what st.
Jude is all about and I said well hey
Ford for greater calls then this game
mm-hmm and now let's talk about your
football camp that's coming up in a
couple of Saturdays from now yeah
the McDaniels second annual youth
football camp what is where's this
taking place and what is it what's it
all about
so it's taking place at my in my
hometown black with New Jersey at my
high school Hina regional high school
and it's just all about giving back and
a lot of guys we hold camps and it's
wonderful I love it I got guys who I
asked to do my camp again this year and
there who only kept the same day so I'm
glad we're all reaching back to
community but my motivation is a little
different I won scholarship I was my
only scholarship when I got that
scholarship
the week before signing day and I I know
what it's like to see the NFL as
something that's impossible and I want
to show the kids like it's possible and
bring a bunch of NFL players back home
and that's why I'm partnered with this
7:07 team wildest NFL program called
next-level greats in LG in South Jersey
and what they do is that they take kids
from you know the tri-state area
Pennsylvania New Jersey New York Marilyn
wherever and they train them and they
you have to see this they train these
kids what do you mean it's amazing so
they have quarterbacks coach and he's
starting these kid one of his kids
actually just signed to a NC State you
know and they they really train these
guys are well they do a lot of footwork
training they do a lot of stuff that I
didn't learn until I got to Iowa and in
the NFL
technique-wise on the field and as a
player so they're also the age group of
15 years I believe the number one 7 or 7
team in the nation and Parma donations
to them and working with them they find
were able to get fully sponsored by
adidas which is awesome so they're
they're really taking a step forward
they're doing the right thing Eve what
over 100 scholarships for kids within
the last 114 under 14 yeah in the last
five years 2013 what do you think of
when you hear NFL players talked about
in a denigrating fashion these days Mike
you don't know what you don't know you
can only go for what is being what you
allowed to be spoon-fed to you some of
these some people have no idea so one
bad apple spoils the bunch
what 2016 players NFL one person gets
caught marijuana there bunch of potheads
one person hits his girlfriend a bunch
of wife abusers so then everybody says
what their motivations for kneeling and
then nobody wants to listen to that so
it's it's like people pick and choose
what they see what they want to see what
they want to hear to fit their narrative
and I think a lot of it stems from
jealousy they think we're spoiled they
think we're overpaid brats so your
father 3 correct absolutely not on the
way how old are your children 6 for one
and then the new baby should be here in
September September yep now the reason
why I asked also is what what what's the
birth dates of your children like
Daniels same do all three children same
two born on the same day same day what
day is that
August 3rd August 3rd now that is Tom
Brady yes well the reason why I know
that is it's my wife it's my wife's
birthday
oh she's greatness there well that she's
a Leo damn yeah I've got three Leo's
that's something about Leo's all know
much about oh they're a little bit
strong-willed sir
they're a little bit strong-willed
that's why how old you say they are yeah
so are you serious they're all been born
on August 3rd so this this newborn that
it's not September so this will be the
first so you have a birthday for all
three of your children the birthday
party yes
how many holy crap that must be I'm just
trying to think the invite list for
children and then parents are coming so
well this is almost like that because
now they're my two oldest are in they're
in school now so it was easier when they
were doing they were babies
man hey just you know come on by now
it's they gotta fight this class you
gotta fight that class and it's I oh my
goodness oh it's my daughter gets that
age it's it's um
I'm trying to just again do the math
with all due respect here August - ten
months are you making the most of your
bye week Mike you know what it's the
mid-season stress midseason stress some
loudest oh you're always honest with me
[Laughter]
[Applause]
can be candid with each other that's
amazing that's the same day yeah is this
planned out it's clearly no not at all
really it just happened and the strange
thing is they would all have different
birthdays if my oldest was a week late
second oldest was two weeks early and
then my daughter was right on time you
know women they don't screw up
you know they know she was right on time
are you kidding me Mike Mike two boys I
believe god bless him my two boys are
nine and seven love them to death I
think they're brilliant they still have
to get on their ass to put their socks
on and my daughter was four is like
doing she could make a gymnastics move
she could do like a puff it's very a
yoga moves craze letting her sock on yes
unbelievable
it's crazy she's my one-year-old justice
herself make sure justice herself makes
sense
sir your fourth child is going to be
born on a date other than August third
most yes yes believable story man
so get ready get ready ready knows that
kid's gonna be like sitting around a
birthday party that their three siblings
are gonna be having this bash that other
one is just gonna be lit that fourth
birthday party well the exact you know
that that when that one has their
birthday party oh man oh now is that you
guys yeah bow to me that's true see the
other thing we want to share our dates
or what have like have separate parties
Alice the morning who stands lose the
evening party a Lambo bouncy house
that's what you're gonna get for that
fourth one sir
that's it just a good idea look I'm
federal Aaron out I everyone knows what
happened and speaking of cut that part
up absolutely and so you got you you
drafted in Iowa Hawkeye to Josh Jackson
where he waited longer than he thought
but you got a really good football
player in the middle of that second
round
so Lucy one of those who's picking off
Aaron is he picked easy pick
okay those two kids him and I sander are
I like what I see from now mm-hmm
pads aren't on yet the real bullets are
flying they haven't played against
anybody different color uniform yet but
to have the confidence to go up against
Aaron Rodgers and I've seen guys kind of
sit on this Aaron they're coming like
okay that's Aaron I respect him but I'm
gonna NFL too
I'm here to compete I said that's them
until you have to have so look out who
else it's true Biscay its lookout Brady
yeah Josh picked up some colors Oh Josh
picked him off to us here so I'm sure
he's not looking for that Arnold look up
oh yeah we do have some rookies and
young guys don't wait do oh good eats
oh good eats fresh meat Mike loved
having you on at Michael 76 come back
you know whenever you're in Los Angeles
come back any time
oh whoa good that's Mike Daniels here
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience